if my kids's being bullied First Step
you tell them hey don't do it second
step you tell a teacher if he continues
you've been instructed by your dad to
use your abilities of Jiu-Jitsu to show
him don't do this again and make sure
you do when there's 20 people around
because there 20 people will be your
publes they're going to go tell
everybody and you will not be fighting
while you're at the school I was always
taught that if someone were to hit you
you don't hit back and you should go
tell a teacher or something like that
how do you balance that and punching
back harder if you get punched first
think about the profile of a bully he
finds targets targets that he's not
afraid of targets that back down do you
watch UFC at all yeah do you know 90% of
these guys when they started fighting
why they started fighting they got
bullied they got bullied and look who
they are now so there's these elements
where you have to stand up if you don't
the bully is going to keep showing up